are there to your mind
any important sunnas of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam that
people avoid because they feel it will
nullify their fast yes there are a few
sunnas of the Prophet which many Muslims
avoid thinking it will break their fast
or it is Mak and the most important
Sunnah of the Prophet which people avoid
doing Ramadan is using the using the
tooth stick many Muslims feel that if
they use this it is Mak the main reason
is there's AI of wasallam a Hadith which
is mentioned in s bukari volume number
three book of fasting Hadith number
194 where the Beloved Prophet mallalli
wasallam said I swear by Allah in whose
hand is the soul of Muhammad peace be
upon him that the breath of the person
who
fasts is more sweeter to Allah than the
scent of musk now based on this Hadi
many Muslims think that if they use the
the breath the bad breath or the foul
breath of the person who fast will not
be there and it will not please Allah
that's the reason they avoid using sah
now these people they fail to realize
that when we use the stick Sak it does
not remove the breath the foul breath
bre or the breath which people normally
don't like of the person who fast the
Sak mainly brushes the gums it cleans
the teeth it helps in keeping the teeth
healthy but in no way does it reduce the
breath especially of the person who fast
and furthermore there's a sun of the
Prophet where prophet wasallam he said
it's mentioned sari volume number
two Hadith number
887 our beloved Prophet M wasallam said
that if it wouldn't have been too hard
for my um I would have made it
compulsory for them to use the Sak the
tooth stick before every prayer or to
use the tooth stick while doing woo like
how wo is a requirement before Salah the
prophet if it wouldn't have been too
difficult for the um you would have made
it compul to you the to stick and here
he did not mention any exceptions other
would have said ADM compos for my um
except during fasting this important
Sunnah surely if this would have been
Mak while fasting would have nullified
the fast surely he would have mentioned
it so this proved that this is important
Sunnah which Muslims should continue
doing even during the month of Ramadan
even while fasting it will not nullify
the fast it's not Mak in fact it is must
it's encouraged and the other important
Sunnah which people neglect or avoid
mainly fearing the that it will spoil
their fast or nullify their fast is
putting water in the nostrils sniffing
the water normally especially during
woodoo so many of the Muslims even when
they do woodoo they just get the water
close to the nose and touch the tip of
the nose to the water that's it they
don't put the water into the nostrils
and they clean their nose they don't
sniff it which is a requirement for
woodu thinking that if they sniff it may
break the fast water entering through
the nose into your throat will nullify
the fast but the chances are very
negligible what our beloved Prophet mam
said it's mentioned a had of Abu da
volume number two had number 2360 our
beloved Prophet said that when you do
woodoo sniff the water excessively
except in fasting so normally when we do
woodoo we sniff the water excessively
except in fasting because in fasting if
we sniff excessively there are chances
though very negligible for it to enter
the throat and nullifying your fast but
normally when we put water in the
nostrils there are no chances of it
going to the throat so only care that we
have to take while fasting is don't
sniff excessively but we have to put the
water in the nostrils and clean the
nostrils which is important Sunnah which
many of the Muslims neglect and they
avoid it especially during Wu and here
since the prophet clearly mentioned
except
fasting during the S he said I would
have made it compulsory had it not been
difficult for my um there because he
doesn't say fasting it means that s can
be used while fasting and sniffing
should not be done excessively but
normally water should be put in the NOS
while doing woodo so these two important
sunnas which people out of ignorance
they avoid during fasting